welcome to this video round 2 for the
candidates in London and we had a very
boring first round I mean you need to be
honest it was boring nothing much
happened today the second round was much
more interesting let's start with the
council Kramnik on paper the game of the
day but yeah but sometimes it's it's a
little bit like if you watch um some
sports yeah we're two top teams play
each other and they have very good
defense it's not so exciting and somehow
all this happened today in this game
we got an English opening here um very
standard position well why it's usual
way to try something it's um the move a3
it doesn't look very exciting I admit
but this is the way I'm Carlton normally
plays this
he got this position for example against
the Judit Polgar in London last year and
this very often leads to a kind of
Hedgehog information with the d6 b 6 and
so on but here you played Bishop f4 so
this must be a preparation but d5 III at
it doesn't look very scary for black and
I have a look we should be for all
normal
developing news we should be - yeah and
now Kramnik simply place the no nonsense
I just want to equalize smoothly to
conceive for and here what is was
supposed to do he took on c6 which is
the relatively best move with you if you
play something like this year you
actually get
position where White has got the
isolated pawn and doesn't have anything
special for it to show I mean that's
already one pair of pieces traded and
yeah it's a it's not great like it's
going to control d5 it's it's very drawn
on some of this position Carlton took on
c6 which is really normal here I mean
not normal in the sense of that this is
a theoretical position but it's the
normal-looking move and everything's
founded easily to to predict 95
attacking c3 attacking f4 and to item
just castled yeah now of course chromium
is not interested in exploring
possibilities like taking here for
example just have a look at this
something like something like this where
white maybe has something pushed up to
d6 45 its compensation for the porn
kramnik just keeps it simple he took on
f4 took on c3 King to e7 and well I mean
I think every every player that and some
at least some basic endgame skulls is
able to hold this even against Carlton
it's it's simply nothing with this
position let's have a look rook b1
Bishop to d7 rook d7 rook b8
so we've got one pair of rooks off but
the problem is that the white rook is
going to get kicked out by blacks King
see the king is just approaching the
rook and now it needs to retreat rook b8
and yeah well what cannot surrender the
B file so the rooks are off also and now
the only thing preventing this game
to be a draw is the 30 move roll rule
they need to play 30 moves before they
agree to a draw and now it's 30 moves
and the game is over so a very very
disappointing game but it's sometimes it
happens if the opening preparation
somehow completely fails it's somewhat
comparable to a Romans game yesterday I
don't know what
Carlton's idea was really we should
afford of course it's not so easy to
predict a certain line but this is a
very common line in the English and
after d5 there are ideas that are more
ambitious like this okay I need to go
back here to actually and alter the
moves and the software you can play
something like this for example
intending 9075 and this is a long
complicated line usually not leading to
much but okay this is somewhat yeah
maybe if you have something prepared
there but he played III and you can
anticipate that all this is very is very
easy Bishop before and now take so
what's the big thing that they missed
you in the preparation it's just nothing
don't know it's just nothing draw well
kramnik with two draws with black in the
first round certainly as is okay with
this result and thousand two draws
against the Aronian and Kramnik is also
not too bad but he certainly I think
would have hoped form for some pressure
in this game and there was nothing okay
next game let's do this quickly Grisha
sweet lon we had some first one in front
of the tournament sweetly playing me
five and here with short castle we have
the introduction to the to the marshal
with c3 and d5
which is not plate it's very difficult
to get something again the marshal so
white players right off and go for a4 or
h3 a4 here's um the move that Kasparov
for example played against Nigel short
in the 1993 match back then short he
played them more than one line he played
awesome at Bishop to b7 in this match
nowadays before is considered to be the
best move and that gives black very
decent equalizing chances d4 d6 and
takes this is one line that white has
tried recently and okay we have a pawn
structure here if four against five with
the open D file this is very common the
difference here is said the Queen side
this operation here has given Y to the
c-4 square for knight or bishop so it it
always tends to be slightly better for
white but it's a very very slight black
also has got good square on c5 and he's
got some some space on the Queen side in
fact in this game after a couple of very
logical looking moves yeah
yeah very simple just take only three
before the night can numb be a be a pest
and now black plays on on those those
weaknesses also supported here with this
Bishop I think black has a pretty
comfortable position it's around equal
and they have continued a bit but it's
always difficult to get some life into a
position where there are no porn breaks
really available it's it's pretty much
symmetrical here what can only play for
f4 at some point and play with pieces
and blacks got enough counter play on on
those weak pawns on the queenside so on
they continued for a bit but the drawing
margin is pretty high here the flight's
tactical sequence IAM but there's really
not much going on at the end was very
very Jewish so on draw a grittier
between those two very good friends also
need to mention that yeah it's difficult
if you play one e4 and you play the Roy
it's it's the Marshall it's very tough
enough to correct they simply don't have
anything this is why those v3 lines for
example move six here d3 years getting
more and more popular so this was the
second draw of this round not too
exciting so now for the more interesting
stuff let's turn to Aronian against
Galvan this is actually my game of the
day if you need to choose one let's go
ahead go hunt playing one c5 and we've
got an English opening with g6 a really
popular line recently this g6 line I
think I played it also in unknown
Yohe on this channel and it's all so
loud I can recommend to two black
players it's quite interesting to to
play there's also a video that I posted
about one year ago where played this is
black against Grandmaster Hoffman here
in the German cap and we had a very
similar line we have this thus now
John's posted to a Carol can pan off
takes and Queen b3 so an isolated pawn
position where this Knight is attacked
and black takes on c3 in the game
against Hofmann I played a six which is
also a good move that you can go for
Knight c3 is seven and the move that
leads to more yeah
unbalanced play maybe the the fun
goofiest Bishop c4 this is what a white
plate he simply delays the capture for
one move and detects some this pawn on
f7 black cannot save the night if he
tries to save it there's this simple
continuation getting the piece back and
giving white a simple win on the board
so what is blacks supposed to do a six
is not good as well
after that takes the problem is if you
go Bishop g7 there's Bishop e3 and you
cannot castle so I'm not too great but
black has a good way to play simply
retreating the piece to continue in this
fashion with these six now the bishop is
detect and white unfortunately must take
there is simply no way to to retreat the
bishop if you retreat it there's more
than one good way to play now Bishop
before is good but also Bishop g7 is a
good news attacking this and intending
95 later like has a very very good
position so white must take retakes
castles and yeah now at one place we
should be sent along it is I recommend
to play Queen d5 here in fact I did a
video on ICC in man German language for
an opening repertoire series where
recommended exactly this means I
recommended the whole line and got to
this point where Queen d5 is the most
popular means white normally goes twin
c3 here and then it continues black and
even play the the funny-looking f6 en
controlling the e5 pawn and he's got a
very strong queen on d5 this is the
justification blacks got two bishops and
a very good queen on d5 in the game
um def on played Bishop e7 first it's
not a big difference probably there
should be three and twenty five the
interesting factors this Bishop e7
gallant had played before in 2012 just
last year against Yaakov bank-owned at
the top GM from Russia and this means
that our own Ian softly had it in his
preparation I mean it's clear that he
must have looked at this line especially
when he decided that he went for Knight
f3 in this game so the preparation
obviously was Bishop III 25 and now rook
c1 so rather quiet continuation here
black has got alternatives to what
Galvan played what girl from played us a
little bit of the gauntlets let's call
it the the grovel means he took on b3
which is not bad really but you asked me
what would you play in this position I
probably wouldn't take I'm not saying
that it is better what I'm suggesting
but it's just a bit more interesting
maybe I would prefer f6 here King f7
covering the square c5 oops
not this one that's also covered but
d 5b v e5 and then probably Bishop here
look to v8 this was my plan and not
exchanged so quickly on v3 I don't know
it's probably somewhat between slightly
better for what in equal but in the game
he took on b3 and what takes on b3 of
course also so why is this a grovel the
problem is here black yeah basically
sacrifices upon it's clear that the c6
pawn is very weak and will get lost at
some point and you can only navigate
around various end games where your pawn
down and where the only question is yeah
well do you draw or do you lose and
while you will draw most of those end
games it's simply a bit of a thankless
tasks you can absolutely never win
unless your opponent drops dead or I
don't know something extraordinary
happens so it's a bit a bit of fun yeah
a bit of a torture to play this ok
played but should be 1795 and castles
and yes the first point where wide down
could grab on c6 it doesn't lead to much
if white takes now that's what we ate
and be counter play black and has got
just enough play to get the pawn back I
mean think of it it's just the b2 pawn
it's not like a big extra central
central pawn or passed pawn or whatever
and black has got lots of play let's say
look here bishop e and now let's let's
say this kind of line and now the
counter play against the two pawns
secures the draw this is why our own Ian
didn't take on c6 he wants to increase
the pressure and look at for us the good
news it intends various switches of the
rook doubling against the a pawn
doubling against the C pawn and this is
the the real problem for black he just
needs to he just needs to wrong word he
needs to buy
the only thing he can do is just make
sure to defend the weaknesses and try to
try to draw and it's not easy at all to
to accomplish let's continue a couple of
moves yeah white um switch over to 85
look at these seven here again there's
the possibility to take pawns knight c6
is even bad for white this is a pretty
bad pin leading to trouble and Knight b7
rook d7 it's also not much let's say
here here and it's questionable if yeah
okay it's a draw I was about to say if
this is unique for for white but it is
equal very equally me oh yeah white
cannot grab him but he played rook
before this is better attacking the
bishop and it has to move and now 96 and
white finally won this pawn without any
big concessions that he needed to make
but it's still not easy for what - to
convert rook p7 he activated to this
piece and now Aronian played h3 a bit of
a mysterious move it's certainly useful
but you would have expected that he
would take on b7 okay HP is not not bad
I'm King g7 is some most of the weddings
and now he didn't find anything else
than to exchange and drop back yeah get
from play Bishop d8 now in this position
he also had the possibility to play
Bishop to g5 which at first I thought
would be quite good attacking the pawn
but rooks is happiness bit annoying you
can actually do this and play for this
endgame but I have a look at this before
takes Bishop g5 and this is
really not much fun look at this
and there are ideas for white you can
try to invade with the king like this or
maybe here I don't know what's class
black can absolutely do nothing you just
need to stay put and will never ever do
anything just very ugly position this is
why not Bishop d5 Bishop T fibers may be
playable but not it's not nice
he played Bishop d8 just preventing
rooks e7 and this is probably better
before and now this is a critical moment
here here black I probably must play
Bishop e5 or let's say any other moves
than what he did he played now rook c8
and you can treat this as as an exercise
as a puzzle
I'll be quiet for a couple of seconds
now so that you have the chance to pause
the video and try to find a good move
for white
okay the good move is and played by
Aronian Bishop h6 check very very
embarrassing to face Delfin just
blundered into this not a good sign for
the rest of the tournament yeah the
problem is if black takes this then
they're simply rook c8 Bishop takes here
here and this is two pawns not just one
two points and this are also not exactly
strong totally winning for white it's
not even difficult technically the nidus
looks a bit stranded but it comes back
into play quickly so taking on h6 is not
not on what else you go here this is
actually quite quite similar takes
and again this is a winning endgame for
white to pause this too much this is
somewhat better compared to the other
line but still still hopeless yeah so
what to do after Bishop h6 yeah yeah
girlfriend needs to retreat but this
leads to a very bleak endgame have a
look the exchanges and Knight to c6 and
now if well theoretically there should
be six would be possible then it
wouldn't be so bad but this just picks
up the bishop on c8 cannot go Bishop e6
and well this thing is saying where do
you go and you need to cover seven also
so there's only one move you should have
six okay so what what have we seen in
this game so far Gavin chose a slightly
passive continuation with taking on b3
and he defended and then he blundered
now in this position white is a pawn up
he's got an active position the knight
on c6 and now what white needs to do is
to display umm yeah good technical play
and this is why I like this this game
really because it's very easy in this
position to make some some careless
moves and then you're in there and need
to really grind how to win and it's not
sure if you if you manage for instance
in this position white could go Knight
xsm the most normal looking means but
look at this Bishop e7 now this is this
is hanging this pawn how do you continue
probably you just still have cover it
you don't want to give it back and then
King f8 and to the King will approach
while white takes a while look at this
if you go here then this pawn would hang
and it's it's not like white is
promoting this be pawn instantly or or
winning a piece or something it isn't an
immediate win it is probably winning in
the long run but it might
50 movies to actually convert it have a
look again at this position what has a
much stronger news Aronian place now b5
and this is very strong the ideas to
delay the capture from one move and
actually give the yeah give black the
chance to make a move what is black
supposed to move here it's close to is
oops one you really have problems to
move he moved the bishop which is
basically the only thing he can do and
now a very strong continuation note that
aronia doesn't take on a seven for
example it is much worse compared to
what you played you played the move g4
this is very very strong
he simply intends to play g5 and
completely dominate this bishop and
black doesn't have any if let's say you
place a six for instance I play g5 where
do you go this is funny
checkmate very nice
oh I have the sound turned off I just
recognized I don't have this check nor
check sounds and checkmates okay Bishop
I Jade would be checkmate and where else
you can go here but this promotes the
pawn no way to stop it the after g4g for
Gelfand play dumb g5 and now again very
very strong powerful play H form he just
forces through this this idea takes g5
and this is just just a sequence of
moves this is that that completely kills
black just go back four moves here
white could easily make himself yeah
make life miserable for himself making
it long long
day at the office with taking on SM man
instead he found this very powerful
sequence of moves h4 took g5 and it's
quite similar to the line that we look
before this Bishop has no square where
should it go if you go here then you
just take and take on a seven and again
this promotes without the bishops
there's no bishop on d4 or anywhere to
stop the pawn this is simply an extra
piece after taking on b5 with an easy
win
so Goffin took here recaptured now only
move Bishop to d8 we must stop this
point and now King G to Bishop c7 King
edge three and he again found reside
simply because white will take on edge
form and then go all the way like to
draw those arrows to promote the the C
pawn black is in a box here like a
coffin this King cannot means it's
simply dominated by this this bishop and
it's simply aware you can play a
desperate f6 at some point but this is
just just another pawn which doesn't
help you so I really liked this game
Aronian did a very very very efficient
job of putting him away here you can
easily make a long end game out of this
which you may be in some cases not even
winning but this b5 and g4 idea was was
just very very strong before g4 h 4g
fight very strong so I'm good
performance if I'm Aronian and very bad
blunder by gelfand it's a very very
unusual for him his some
when one of his main strength is
actually that he he rarely blunders and
this is heaven today he even had enough
time on the clock so how to explain okay
so now I'll take a look at the last game
here a job of against even shock I want
to concentrate on the later stages of
the game
surprisingly even shock with some some
order twists went into the the Leningrad
Dutch very sharp opening that you
wouldn't expect on a on a candidate
turtle controller championship but okay
he went for a t1 shock is a very
enterprising player and he managed to
surprise a job of you see he spent 20
minutes for this very common theoretical
position look be one who is an
interesting way to play Kramnik played
this against Nakamura a couple of years
ago the ideas a quick before b5 mantra
played 94 twin c2 and takes on c3 yeah
this actually is what happened in this
chronic game against Nakamura as well it
is some it is so interesting before as
one idea and here even shall played in a
very straightforward man I played e5 and
I'm not sure if this was really a good
idea the problem is that white is very
quick now with his pieces with black is
pretty much undeveloped and white now
very quickly um gets his forces into
play
basically all pieces play now the rook
yeah the roofs from both falls and the
bishop is strong so it's it's it doesn't
doesn't look like a good position for
black queenie 8 and before yeah white
tries to open up maybe around here you
need to look for improvements you've
answered plate f4 and this could have
led to big trouble already now if her
job of would have played Knight g5 p.m.
which she didn't for some reason Knight
g5 is however quite strong just
attacking the look and maybe after Luke
f6 he didn't appreciate Queen d3
directly threatening Queen D aid and
this is really rather annoying position
for black what do you do now he's very
much on the defensive what her job of
plate was not so good but it wasn't so
as far as well as 95 he played rook to
e3 took on g3 and 986 yeah this night
isn't doing so much really but what was
black supposed to do it it really looks
like a bad position 95 looked to c7 way
to go we should be 6 yeah it's um it's
not much fun how do you whether you go
with this rook you go here there's this
possible ooh team like it's black it's
in big trouble
Yvonne Chaka actually decided to to go
form for sacrifice in this position he
played for Queen sac he didn't overlook
this move here Bishop takes me 5 we
sacrificed the Queen with this maneuver
hoping for for some some miracle let's
put some more moves on the board white
just consolidated and I did a good job
of controlling the position I'm not sure
that Queen takes was so great but it is
enough
okay frugal fate so we are on move 30
yeah if I shop was down two seconds and
the clock times are not 100% exact year
but he was down on seconds maybe 20
maybe 30
it gives 23 ICC but something around
that and a job of down to 4 minutes he
played Queen no Bishop this move needs
to be inserted night d3 age 4 and now I
played the Queen to a5 b6 and here what
probably just needs to go Queen 8 form
and will win the game he's got 2 points
extra and Queen against rook and Bishop
black only has got some slight counter
play it's it's really not enough there's
this hanging and sometimes you just can
take it here what a job of did is also a
very natural move I mean probably I
would have played this as well it's not
like I'm saying he'd he he is a complete
[ __ ] for doing this it's just it took
on be 60 are just returning the exchange
and the thing is sort of like a miracle
black can draw in this position by force
which is at first hard to believe but he
can and this is by means of the move G
foam it's not apparent immediately why
but I can give you a couple of lines f4
is probably the most testing but let's
start with night x t5 this even loses
takes on f3 King everyone takes on g3
and first two pawns a deadly white
cannot save himself let's say rook P 1 F
2 and it's it's over this is just deadly
the Jeep on also in connection with
Nadia for sometimes this even loses the
game
so what is why it's supposed to do it
this is threatened f4 really looks like
the way to go
and then black has h3 check King edge to
and now rook th this is the big point
for white X now and the thing is he
doesn't have a move what should you do
this thing is hanging and you cannot use
it well it doesn't make any sense to go
to you one for example so let's take
here and this is whoops this is a check
and in fact we have a perpetual no way
for Y to get out of this if you go here
then oops sorry
in this position of course this move I
forgot here
and this is indeed the perpetual why
cannot go here because of this made now
so let's return all the way back so what
else can you go somewhere else let's say
he goes to h1 it's just the same thing
or to f1 then black has the great booth
rook h7 supporting the H bond he can
really afford to do that it's it's quite
amazing what is White's supposed to do
probably he needs to even return here
and h2 it might even need to travel for
what if you now try to stop this
mechanically there's rook e8 and and an
attack so it's completes quite amazing
what must force to draw this this
perpetual that I showed earlier g4 out
of nothing is a miracle safe it's really
a dead draw funny enough I checked it
with the computer of course it gives
zero zero zero but even shock was down
two seconds according to Isis here to
nine seconds and it didn't manage to do
that he just took on v6 Queen b6 took on
g3 and now it is over because he oneshot
overstep the time limit while he took on
g3 so he lost some time but the position
now is also hopeless one can can take
this year and and win because also this
you need to note that one can take
getting getting the the night at the end
is called for extra points and to
promote at least one of them so this
game was mostly interesting for this
miracle save here G form amazing there
are tons of ways to lose and have a look
at this takes here takes here what is
why it's supposed to do King here check
f2 and black is winning it's it it's
it's really it's really funny because
those pieces are not playing yeah very
very fun end of of this game it could
have been with the g4 but I think all in
all it is a victory for a job of because
he oneshot really got outplayed terribly
in the opening so on after two rounds we
have Aronian a leading together with
them raja baath and i'm glad to show two
two decisive games after the very timid
first round hope you enjoyed it and I'll
be back tomorrow
Thanks